hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday Hokkien April 30th 2018 what's
going on how are you I'm still sick I
just I just every time I start to get
healthy I travel again so I actually had
to reschedule a gig something I've never
don't can't remember the last time I did
that so because I just need to [ __ ]
stay home and I'm just having coughing
fits I'm having an absolute [ __ ] fit
at night like my throat sounds like this
I still got the sniffles and maybe I got
a bola you know but I'm kind of alright
Eickhoff a little bit during the day but
the second I lay down at night I thought
my throat gets all dry and I just have
this coughing fit now I'm saying this to
you guys because all of you now without
medical degrees are now leaping to your
feet and you know exactly what's wrong
with me and what the cure is and that's
my favorite thing about being sick I
like to not go to doctors I like to talk
to people who have talked to doctors I
went on Web MD and then they [ __ ]
diagnosed me so I just think I need to I
need to shut it down for a couple of
[ __ ] days and not do anything it's
what I need to do but I mean if I am
doing the [ __ ] podcast I want to
thank everybody that came out to in
Hotlanta to the show at the Fox Theater
I know I sounded like [ __ ] but I think I
had a good show and then the next day
like an [ __ ] rather than just being
like Bill you're sick you know don't do
the plan fun event and just go home and
sleep it off I couldn't lay off man I
went to the Talladega Superspeedway and
I went to that NASCAR race out there man
and
just had a great great time legendary
legendary track that's where they always
have the big one the big ones come you
don't know when it's coming all you know
all you really know is that it's coming
the big one is just they can drive so
goddamn fast they're that eventually you
know and they're right on each other's
bumpers eventually all it takes is
somebody to do a little shimmy little
shimmy shimmy shimmy shimmy shake
whatever the [ __ ] it is shaking bike
choke it on my own spit
all right do a little Ricky Bobby [ __ ]
little Brewster Baker a little stroke a
race try to think of all the stock car
movies I saw sorry we're breathing too
many fumes and then they just have like
a giant [ __ ] crash there so you know
the deal you know as Tony Stewart said
we can we come there for the accidents I
don't see anybody died but I want to see
[ __ ] fly through the [ __ ] air so we
were in this suite then we watched like
the first couple legs of the race and
then I was just like dude I want to go
outside and I want to [ __ ] you know I
want to hear the cars and all that [ __ ]
so we went the upper deck was just as
[ __ ] as you can see the whole goddamn
track and then we were like let's go
down low because it was more seats and
we went down there and it's that whole
thing is like 40 [ __ ] cars go by at
like you know 180 hundred ninety 20
miles an hour and all you're thinking is
if if they got if they have the big one
right not right in front of me because
by the time everything you know settles
it's gonna be [ __ ] two miles down I'm
a quarter mile down the [ __ ] track
it's like if it happens right before me
there is a chance I could take a lot
lugnut to the side of my head and I'll
be [ __ ] dead you know but it is
amazing I got to tell you and the people
down there we're [ __ ] great
I've always been a fan of [ __ ]
Alabama it's a beautiful goddamn state
but I will I will tell you this not to
get negative and [ __ ] just in general
there is a level of [ __ ] poverty
that you just cannot [ __ ] but like
some of the people something I just five
about a long time ago Patrice O'Neal
told me this thing was [ __ ] hilarious
she said you know some bill he goes
black people we are good at being broke
and I go he talking about he goes look
at us he goes we had we have the
cleanest [ __ ] on the earth you
wouldn't know that we're broke even if
we are broke but let me tell you
something about white people when a
white person is broke you [ __ ] know
it and that's what an I was thinking
about as I always do I always think of
[ __ ] that he said and I just was looking
at these [ __ ] people man some not all
of them but just that was there's been a
few when I've been traveling there's
been a few times where I've seen little
kids and I've had the urge to rescue
them you know by the time you're looking
at the adults you like it's too late for
them you know I've seen that in inner
cities I saw it in India and I saw it in
Alabama Talladega not everybody I'm not
saying everybody but there was
definitely some [ __ ] people I was
like that kid if you get him out of this
environment he has he's got [ __ ] hope
Jesus Christ I owe you know something
when you hear that [ __ ] white privilege
and stuff you can say that to me but I
always like going to that race I was
wondering what those people think you
know cuz the the bus definitely skipped
their stuff and I'm not talking down on
these people because I [ __ ] hate our
people up north and people on the coast
and everything they got this [ __ ]
attitude like you know if you whiten
you're broke it's because you dumb and
that's just ignorant because you haven't
[ __ ] traveled but uh haven't said
that there was a disturbing amount of
Confederate flags that I saw but like I
don't know I don't I don't I don't I
don't get that aspect of it but the
other ship I'm just talking about feet
coming out of the side of your [ __ ]
sneakers I don't know it was it was it
was it was interesting definitely as a
fellow American I was like you know we
really should be doing something about
this
can we try to help these [ __ ] people
oh now I don't Trump said he was gonna
do it he was gonna make it great again
and I could tell you right now that I
didn't see a lot of greatness there oh
[ __ ] why do why do I talk about things
why do I see things and then talk about
things you know what because that's what
I do
I didn't talk to you no I actually
talked to a lot of people when I was
there I had a you know a good time but
there was definitely a few people that
just had to take pictures of you know
but I'm not gonna post them just because
you know I don't I don't want to further
any sort of [ __ ] stereotypes and the
people in the NASCAR treated me great
but there's definitely I saw this
[ __ ] guy he had on overall shorts is
the only way to describe it and Larry
Bird's short shorts and the whole thing
was the American flag and cowboy boots
with no shirt underneath it shaved head
and sunglasses you know he looked like
Rob Halford on the 4th of July is the
only way to describe and he was stand
next to a guy it just [ __ ] bare feet
looking like he walked out of a coal
mine and it was [ __ ] just some old
school [ __ ] and people just smoking like
chimneys like a lot of people smoking
down there and it reminded me of when I
was a kid like the level that people
were smoking but having said that there
was also a bunch of other people that
look fine I'm just saying but there was
definitely some people who just like god
damn that guy is [ __ ] broke you know
how are you a lot and your that broke
what they're saying out there is that's
not supposed to happen you're supposed
to just [ __ ] wake up you know then
everything all the doors are supposed to
swing open for you with your Hawaii
vilage well that happened for me people
it did not happen for those people you
know I you know what I think a lot of it
goes back to I think it goes back to the
Civil War when you lose a [ __ ] war
like that
they're the repercussions of that you
deal with that for a long [ __ ] time
and you know I knew some people that
relocated from the north down to the
south back in the 80s some friends of
mine their parents moved or whatever and
I just remember them calling me up and
they were going dude I'm learning [ __ ]
in school right now that I learned
[ __ ] two years ago up north this is
[ __ ] ridiculous it's no [ __ ]
reason for that there is no reason for
that so I don't know did I mention the
race was [ __ ] awesome I was just a
little taken aback by [ __ ] like that you
know you like to see that you don't like
to see that anyway right I always seen
people struggling you know not having
the answers walking around in jean
shorts
but anyways great [ __ ] food at the
track Jesus Christ it was delicious food
had this barbecued [ __ ]
something-or-other the coleslaw and
everything was absolutely delicious and
and I love the track legendary track and
then I love the [ __ ] the bleachers it
was just no frills no [ __ ] you know
look like an old football stadium when
there's just like we're just building
[ __ ] seats that's it no [ __ ] sushi
stands and under that crap there's
definitely a good time I hope that
didn't come off like some elitist Yankee
thing anyways plowing ahead now now
we're gonna get into my elitist attitude
for the week now this is something that
everybody's gonna be like first world
problem and all that I I have a [ __ ]
problem with Delta Airlines all right
these [ __ ] [ __ ] for whatever
reason they bored first class and
they're premium select whatever they
call them their [ __ ] medallion
members at the same [ __ ] time you
know all these widget salesmen that fly
every [ __ ] weekend it's like ice
20 years in the back of the [ __ ]
plane with the stress of the back of the
plane like [ __ ] I need to line up an
hour before the flight so I get on early
enough so there's going to be a place
for my [ __ ] bag oh is this a dc9 am I
is is the engine right outside my window
and a parts gonna fly off into my
[ __ ] head am i next to the bathroom
I'm gonna smell the piss and [ __ ] of the
[ __ ] working-class I spent 20 years
in the back of that [ __ ] plane and
they kept us back there and we didn't
get on until first class got on and we
were not allowed curtain that was their
[ __ ] bathroom I did every goddamn
hell gig I had [ __ ] thrown at me I got
booed I got [ __ ] out of money and I
moved up the rows pop up I got up to the
exit row at that I got all the way up
there now I can finally afford to sit up
front right and I don't give a [ __ ] that
there like anybody with a limp or a
yeast infection
anybody active military even if you
never saw action even if all you do is
count their grenades rather than [ __ ]
throw them you can get on first I don't
give a f--- II got a stroller and a kid
you're old and in a wheelchair not a
[ __ ] problem with that these [ __ ]
[ __ ] they take all their frequent
flyers and then these [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right they line up like a
half-hour before so I'm like where's the
first-class line they go it's right here
I look back I'm like 40th in [ __ ]
line and now I got the anxiety again
that's not that is not first class first
class is you walk on without a [ __ ]
care in the world that's what I paid for
I walk on without a care in the world
and you pretend that I'm better than the
people behind me that is what I'm paying
for and that is not the experience you
get on Delta Airlines all of these
[ __ ] people just [ __ ] why can't
you just board first class in two
seconds later I have those [ __ ]
premium [ __ ] they line up like a half
hour before
now I gotta stand up I don't even use
frequent flyer I pay full price for the
[ __ ] ticket cuz I can't figure out
how to do the [ __ ] I don't want to
figure it I don't figure out you know
how many [ __ ] miles I have with you
[ __ ] what is the particular price
hey you go the way a guy shops I'm not
waiting for the sale I need pants
those are pants what are they here this
is given to me so I [ __ ] get on the
plane and I get on a plane and all the
first-class [ __ ] bids are taken but I
see one one that's like [ __ ] two rows
behind me and I feel that that [ __ ]
anxiety that [ __ ] anxiety that gave
me the drive to get up to the front of
the [ __ ] plane and then I'm sitting
there right I finally [ __ ] sit down
and all of this [ __ ] right and I know
you guys are like Bill well quit your
[ __ ] whining [ __ ] you it's what I say
I'll say it again [ __ ] you alright don't
call it [ __ ] first class and don't
charge me for first I want a first class
experience you know so many people sit
in the back of the plane let's say you
went on wheel of fortune and you solve
the [ __ ] puzzle alright and they said
that they were going to give you
first-class accommodations in Laughlin
Nevada alright well if you came walking
into the hotel and you didn't get to go
to VIP check and you still just stand in
line with all these flip-flop where and
[ __ ] overeaten jackasses it's that
the first-class experience you know what
I mean they treated me like a $3 [ __ ]
you got a $3 [ __ ] you're expecting a
certain level attitude but when you get
a $1,200 to $2,000 [ __ ] call girl
she's supposed to pretend you're
interesting and your stories are
fascinating that you're paying for the
experience I'm just letting you know
that experience does not exist on Delta
Airlines you're gonna get on the [ __ ]
plane with the first-class seat that you
[ __ ] paid for with 40 other [ __ ]
people in front of you with their neck
and their [ __ ] and God all this other
cool Tremont's they need because those
poor bastards are still sitting in the
back of the plane well I paid good money
I paid good goddamn money for the
fantasy that I am above those people and
I did not get that and I hope mr. and
mrs. Delta Airlines here this [ __ ]
thing and I hope I hope they try to come
at me with some sort of voucher some
sort of gift certificate for a brownie
sundae the next time I go back to the
Atlanta Jackson [ __ ] Airport this is
the thing all this [ __ ] waving in my
arms they're not gonna [ __ ] change it
they're not gonna change it and I'm
still gonna fly their [ __ ] airline
when I have to because I don't have any
I don't have any no I'm not basically an
American Airlines guy you know an
American Airlines when you fly
first-class you get on with the
first-class people you sit down you
[ __ ] fine and you know what you are
you're an inspiration you're an
inspiration to the rest of those
passions there's passengers that walk
past you on American Airlines they're
looking at you going look at that sickly
bald looking redheaded guy if I work
hard enough someday I'll be him getting
on the plane without a care in the
[ __ ] world
he's like Delta Airlines you're getting
on with those same [ __ ] people you
know those people that are so fat they
got the crease in the back like a
toddler you know toddlers have those
cute rolls of fat you know what I mean
there's a certain level of fat that you
get to you should literally have your
arms up you know the way a little baby
walks why am i attacking fat people in
order I just I've traveled I don't even
know how many [ __ ] miles I travel but
let's put it this way when I saw that
George Clooney movie where he was trying
to get a million miles I wasn't
impressed all right but that man was
doing was pedestrian no and then you met
the woman you found out later she was
married welcome to the road buddy am I
supposed to feel bad for you with you a
full head of beautiful salt-and-pepper
[ __ ] hair
your villain Indian [ __ ] Italy am i
stalking him alright I want his life
anyways I just don't like that Delta has
put me in the position to expose myself
for the elitist [ __ ] that I am alright
I'm not saying that I'm better than the
people in the back of the plane what I'm
saying is is I got paid to be treated
better than them and I don't want to be
lumped in with all these [ __ ] contest
winners all these [ __ ] widget
salesmen that fly your goddamn airline
every [ __ ] [ __ ] weekend so that
now this then they they port what the
[ __ ] did they pay for that ticket 300
bucks you get none with me
how dare Delta mrs. and mrs. Delta
Airlines they should I should have got a
[ __ ] discount on my tea I just wish
there was a [ __ ] phone number that
you could call and actually talk to a
person and I could just be like the
biggest [ __ ] ever when I get on your
airline I do not even want to see people
be on the other selling occurred during
the [ __ ] flight like people just
walleston right up just using the
[ __ ] bat everybody gets up
everybody's in first place the [ __ ] out
of here
get out of here with your a comedy
economy seating shits you take those in
the back buddy you take that in the back
I don't want to listen to you [ __ ]
sit upon farts up here okay this is
first class we have silverware no I
don't give a [ __ ] if you use the pad I
don't give a [ __ ] about any of it the
only thing I [ __ ] want is what I'm
paying for is you go first class and I
just mosey on to the [ __ ] plane and
stick my bag right above my chair and I
sit in a chair that's actually fit to be
used by a human being that's all I'm
[ __ ] paid for I don't give a [ __ ]
about your meals and all of that other
[ __ ] and that you call me mister
barone ass in fact you can take my
[ __ ] hoodie and go hang it up I don't
give a [ __ ] about all of that
I'm paying for no anxiety like it is the
been gonna be there I all of that is
supposed to be God you know it's like
winning the lottery
that's what flying first classes you
flight this is the thing about further
you fly first class you don't want the
flight to end that's how great first
class is supposed to be Delta has
somehow lost it they think they forgot
what the [ __ ] it was you know what I
mean you know what I blame all of this
on you know what I blame all of this
[ __ ] on [ __ ] dress casual Fridays
casual Fridays [ __ ] ended it it
[ __ ] ended it in this goddamn country
I'm old enough to remember when all of a
sudden casual Fridays it's how old I am
I remember when that [ __ ] came out and
somebody I was working in the warehouse
and somebody from the carpeted area just
started working there you know what I
mean that was during this is the 80s
this is like the Michael J Fox era so
you know what I mean you got yourself a
skinny tie and a [ __ ] cubicle and you
bought a Ford Probe you know whatever
the [ __ ] days to call those [ __ ] cars
you got like a silver roof you know and
this [ __ ] little Michael J Fox guy
goes what's what's what's casual Fridays
and I made the joke ago all that's when
everybody dresses like us basically like
you're unloading a truck and I my boss
got upset by that try to have some big
[ __ ] meeting about it and mr. Bursch
said that that's when everybody drives
dresses like us and that's stuck with me
and I feel like we should have more
pride out here in the warehouse and [ __ ]
it but love him he's just he had a bunch
of [ __ ] hungover musicians and class
clowns working out there we just stare
at this guy going to poor showing up
like we always show up okay if you think
we're gonna [ __ ] show up like it's
the 1950s and we work in an ice cream
parlor to go unload trucks that's not
happening so that failed but yeah
everything has just become like
everybody's just [ __ ]
down-to-earth now sort of as the middle
class shrinks I don't understand it okay
do you know back in the day when you
flew first this is how far we [ __ ]
come when you flew first class on Pan Am
and you flew into JFK International
Airport back before every airport said
they were international you know what I
mean that's like every [ __ ] podcast
out there claims they have like a
million [ __ ] downloads or the number
one and something you know what I mean
every [ __ ] Airport now says they're
international well you know you connect
from our airport to an actual
International Airport next thing you
know you're in Europe so I think we're
international that's like the second
assist in hockey the [ __ ] out of here is
second assist you knew that [ __ ] guy
was gonna pass it to the other guy you
get a point to [ __ ] my train of thought
what was my point
Oh back in the day the Met Life Building
in New York right abrupt grubbé read
above Grand Central Station just be the
Pan Am building well back in the day
when you flew first class in Pan Am you
landed at JFK you got off that [ __ ]
plane from up top where there was a guy
playing a goddamn piano okay you're up
there the summer wind came blowing in
won't you suck my dick right there's
nothing to people go well what happened
all the good-looking stewardesses and
all that L because there's no money they
deregulated the whole [ __ ] thing and
then every [ __ ] jerk-off with flip
flops could use the first-class bathroom
and then all those good-looking women
are like well there's none o but he to
Gold dig on this thing I'm [ __ ] out of
here that's what happened okay you take
the money the money goes out the window
so does all the beautiful women it's
like a vacuum they get sucked right the
[ __ ] out now everybody on the flight
looks like [ __ ] Alice from The Brady
Bunch
oh god drinking this [ __ ] cold and
flu herbal shot Oh God
it's got to be the dandelions or some
[ __ ]
like god that's better anyways I was
sorta gonna finish this [ __ ] story
when you flew first class on Pan Am to
JFK International Airport when you got
off that [ __ ] plane you didn't go
into the airport with those animals you
didn't you got off that [ __ ] thing
and they watch you over to a [ __ ]
helicopter okay and you're like Ron
Burgundy you know with a scarf around
your neck and you have glass of scotch
you [ __ ] walked over to that thing
you got on that they flew you from
Brooklyn right up and over all the
traffic landed you on top of the Pan Am
building and you know what was up there
there was a bar beautiful women rich
people and all this [ __ ] you got off
into that world and you had another
scotch you talked to some women or
whatever right well you made a [ __ ]
business connection and then when you
were ready to go somebody took your bags
you went down in the elevator and right
into a [ __ ] cab over to your goddamn
hotel and probably somebody put a little
[ __ ] eight-ball in your breast coat
pocket we've gone from that to what I
experienced in Atlanta on mr. and mrs.
Delta Airlines okay I missed it I missed
the my window of when first class was
first class sometimes you just got to
admit that you missed it like I feel bad
for Millennials like when I look at all
this [ __ ] that they're going through and
all these climate change and all this
crap that they gotta have to [ __ ]
deal with the ramifications up I look
back you know as I'm dealing with
turning 50 I'm like you know what it's
kind of cool that I got to live through
the 70s 80s and 90s you know and I think
oh no now when I look at people in their
60s 70s and 80s and I'm thinking like
you know what that guy right there
that guy probably
got his dick sucked on a helicopter ride
from JFK over to the top of the Pan Am
building that guy knows what first
classes all right I don't want to hear
it I don't want to hear it from the
people in the back of the plane what a
spoiled brat I am I don't give a [ __ ] I
am so beyond you that I won't even read
your emails I can tell by the font that
you sit in the back of the plane what do
you have a long no kidding I'm just
saying you don't know me what the [ __ ]
can I just get on the [ __ ] plane all
I'm asking for I don't need a helicopter
ride I don't need a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
can I just get on the [ __ ] plane in a
relaxed manner and just put my bag up
there this what the [ __ ] I paid for okay
and then you can come to me and be like
um do you you want the eggs or the
oatmeal can I get the eggs I'm sorry
we're all out of eggs that happens in
first class what do you mean you're out
of eggs its first class so I met voices
crackers first [ __ ] class you should
still have them yeah I got a sec let me
take another shot a [ __ ] dandelion
root oh oh I'm starting to like that
reminds me when I did the landscape
before [ __ ] one stone all right dokey
you know talk about how every man looks
better in his suit
oh yeah every man looks better to suit
especially back in the day what first
classes first class and you would wear a
suit trying to impress those goddesses
that used to work up there you know and
they pretended that you were funny and
that your stories were [ __ ]
interesting and then they they [ __ ]
danced you over to a goddamn helicopter
in your beautiful fitted suit endo Chino
it's the world's largest made-to-measure
menswear company that has been featured
in major publications including GQ
Forbes off and Fast Company I don't know
what that last one doesn't kind of
tapered off in the last one they make
suits and shirts made to your exact
measurements for a great
guys love the wide selection of high
quality fabrics and the option to
personalize all the details including
your lapel lining and monogram here's
how it works
visit a showroom or shop online at endo
chino calm pick your fabric choose your
customizations submit your measurements
wait for your custom suit to arrive in
just a few weeks
this week's my listeners can get any
premium I hate that word at this point
after watching what the premium people
got getting too bored at the same time
is my privileged white freckled ass any
premium Indochina suit for just 379
bucks in Indo Chino comm when entering
birbee you are are a checkout that's 50%
off the regular price for a
made-to-measure
premium suit plus shipping is free
that's Indochina comm promo code bar for
any premium suit for just $379 and free
shipping incredible deal for a suit that
will fit you better than anything off
the rack ever could
all right oh look who it is it's the
black tux
just like the Ohio State dude I [ __ ]
love this [ __ ] that's dandelion stuff
mm-hmm oh jesus what a [ __ ]
aftertaste
then it gets good starts tasting
metallic showing us draw the black tux
the black tux wedding season is upon us
I'm so happy I'm on the other so you
know and sometimes when I see somebody
in a wedding I'm just I'm so glad that
I'm on the other side of that you know
and then I look at people that have
started a family and they're done having
kids you know because what's debating
possibly having another one I don't know
I'm pretty [ __ ] old at this point
what am i Tony Randall but like when I
just see somebody and said they're
married they have the amount of kids
that they're gonna have and they're just
on the other side of it okay they've
taken though they did they set sail this
is what we're doing you know that
together the [ __ ] is working you know
even though I had I would have one I had
one of the great weddings of all time
and it's such a great time man adjust
these stress
you know I have anxiety I have anxiety I
think that's what it is
I'm always thinking like like where
where's the [ __ ] slap to the side of
the head comes from anyway sweating
season is upon us you're going to be
doing it big and going all out alright
going going out to all of your buddy's
weddings nice copy I like that your
buddy's weddings you're not you're not
the one locked and loaded you're not
locked in you're not getting
waterboarded you're the free guy running
around with you bowtie off banging all
the [ __ ] drunk chicks when you're
bringing a date you want to look fresh
but it has to be convenient who brings a
[ __ ] date to a wedding that's the
dumbest thing you could ever do when are
you gonna ask me engage that's where the
black tux comes in [ __ ] Ted you've got a
tux you go stag the black tux has
answers it has awesome suits and tuxedos
and all kinds of styles and you rent
them online there you go you get off you
get a tuxedo with a little bit of flair
you show up you know with you little
pompadour you just all you got to do is
act like you're interesting
you know the anxiety that women feel at
a wedding that it's not them I'm telling
you right now they're gonna fall right
in your [ __ ] lap just wait for a slow
song to come on you know we both would
have poison at their wedding at this
point somebody getting married for the
third time the black deep black tux
offers the kinds of suits and tuxedos
styles that would normally be wildly
expensive to buy and you might only wear
it once like the Emerald shawl tuxedo
it's funky [ __ ] it's cool but
how many times you're gonna wear it how
many times you're gonna wear an emerald
green tuxedo with the black tux you can
do you can do you and blow it out for
your big one pick one time event I can't
read anymore with the black tux free
home try on you can see the fit and feel
the quality of your suit months before
your
after all honoring oh you know against
all his balls your suit will arrive 14
days before your event if anything is
less than perfectly black tux we'll send
you a replacement right away
and remember how simple returns are wear
it turn heads then send it back three
days after your event shipping is free
both ways stand out at your event for
the right reasons with the black tux to
get $20 off your purchase visit the
black tux comm / / that's the black tux
comm / berg for $20 off your purchase
the black tux premium rental suits and
tuxedos still live oh my god I got two
more of these oh but they're nice and
short because these people understand my
intellect Dollar Shave Club dude if you
have a shower a brush your teeth or try
to make you hey you look presentable
here's some good news
Dollar Shave Club has a lot of stuff to
help you out Dollar Shave Club
yes that's Dollar Shave Club what Dollar
Shave Club delivers everything you need
to look feel and smell your best you
name it shampoo conditioner body wash
toothpaste hair gel even a white that'll
leave you touch feeling tingling and
clean so fresh and so clean you'll be a
big fan of their amber and lavender
calming body cleanser after you try it
the first time I just immediately
envisioned someone stealing like [ __ ]
kidneys after they put that [ __ ] on me
good luck finding a product that great
at the store all of Dollar Shave club's
products are made with top-shelf
ingredients that won't break your budget
you feel the difference plus shipping is
free with your membership the only thing
they're missing is a lube for you to rub
one out with and here's a great way to
get a bunch of Dollar Shave Club
products for just five bucks you can get
their daily essential status set it
comes with body cleanser one white
cherry
they're amazing butt wipes their
world-famous shave and their best razors
the six blade executive keep the blades
coming for a few more bucks a month and
a chin shampoo toothpaste or anything
else you need speaking of your next
month for a limited time only you
code birth check out to get $5 off your
second month of the club that's code
Brett dollarshaveclub.com to save $5 on
your second month
join the club today all right stamps
calm everybody I think I need a shot at
dandelion juice here hmm
oh yeah my wife asked me she was what
does that taste like I said burnt
eyelashes how do you know that's just
the first thing I thought
stamps.com use postal you US Postal
Service is an important tool for any
business stamps.com is the easiest way
to access all the amazing services of
the post office stamps calm never
[ __ ] closes print postage for letters
or packages at your convenience 24/7
print postage for any mail class right
now for your computer the exact amount
of postage every time never under pay
over pay again I can mail any letter any
package using just my computer and
printer and the mail carrier picks it up
mail everything from postcards to
envelope to packages domestic or
international create your stamps calm
account and minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no long-term
commitments I use stamps calm because I
have a new poster coming out for my new
tour that's simply called 50 and not
fitty not 50 sets 50 as in this old
white man is half a century old that I
will be selling and I need to get those
things over to [ __ ] in Dublin into
London and to whatever the [ __ ] else I'm
gonna be and I use stamps calm because
if I can figure it out so can you
alright now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale go to stamps
com click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in bar that
stamps.com enter bar all right let's
talk hockey playoffs playoffs you
kidding me
playoffs
goddamnit that was [ __ ] delicious
it's a free appetite dr. Schultz is cold
and flu herbal shut the aftertaste is
terrible but whatever remains on your
tongue is incredible I like it remember
that Chevy Chase we did that giant line
of love I liked it
nothing summed up the 70s in the 80s
like that quick little joke all right
hockey playoffs the Bruins jumped all
over Tampa Bay in Game one to go up one
nothing
once again our top line was absolutely
killing it Tuukka Rask was playing
[ __ ] great
Nebraska whatever I didn't know half the
guy's [ __ ] names were like when I'm in
the other room and somebody scores a lot
of the time I have to poke my headed to
see who it is because we changed so many
players just this season with the kid I
probably watch five full games and
anyways and then game to Tampa was just
the better team they just came out like
they were ready to play and we just
don't know every time we had the puck it
was like it was on edge and so whatever
it's wonder why but we did what we had
to do we won one down there and now
we're coming back and I hope we get up a
more competent officiating crew cuz
those guys were just it was like they
were off and whatever they made some
[ __ ] bad calls but that happens
sometimes the calls go your way
sometimes they don't you know whine
about it you pick up and move on but you
know when the [ __ ] net is off the
goddamn moorings whatever the [ __ ] they
call it and the goalies like dude for
like a half a [ __ ] minute they just
don't see it like date that was not
ready for primetime officiating you know
I just hope I just don't want it to come
down to that because I think the Tampa
is a great team and I want I want to see
Tampa beat us or the Bruins beat them I
just you know that is a
peeve of mine that you know you start
calling ticky-tack [ __ ] and you start
like you know dictating the tone of the
game and then all of a sudden you stop
calling ticky-tack [ __ ] it's just weird
you know what I mean and then you
letting [ __ ] go and then all of a sudden
you call and stuff I mean that's the
type of [ __ ] you know back in the day
when I used to watch the NBA was like
what the [ __ ] you know the [ __ ] is fixed
speaking of the NBA
I was working Saturday night and missed
everything about that Celtics game 7
against Milwaukee I have not even seen a
highlight I am very happy that we won I
heard we kind of wanted you know
wire-to-wire and and then last night the
weirdest thing ever like this Boston
Celtics had a [ __ ] playoff game while
the Bruins had a playoff game and we
beat the the formidable Philadelphia
76ers when is that next game and I can't
last time I think we played each other
in the playoffs I have to go back to
like 82 81 82 83 way back in the day all
right game 2 is when Thursday well I
hope that's not going to overlap with
the Bruins [ __ ] am I supposed to do I
want to see this
the overachieving Celtics with all the
goddamn injuries this is tremendous and
my picks in the NBA Finals before it
started and you can check with the great
and always lovely Dom IRA that's what
I've always loved about his act it's not
the top shelf joke writing it's the
elegance of his performance IIE asked me
what I thought and I picked Toronto in
the East in Golden State because I
figured Golden State at Cleveland we're
gonna one of them's gonna make it back
and I don't know I'm just impressed with
Toronto he's got a lot of weapons and
[ __ ] and blah blah blah blah blah and
and like LeBron is played like the
equivalent of 60 years with all the
[ __ ] playoffs that that guy's been
involved in so anyways those those are
my god
dan picks and as far as hockey goes I
don't know it's hard to go against the
Penguins getting back there again but I
think the most interesting series right
now is obviously the Predators and
Winnipeg Jets I would not want to have
to play either one of them and I'm
psyched one of them is gonna knock the
other one off all right there's my
limited [ __ ] view of what the [ __ ]
going on all right Punk suggestions the
[ __ ] did you call me all right I was
listening to your podcast and you asked
someone for suggestions on hardcore punk
music I thought I'd try and email you
from here I would start with bands like
Minor Threat I've heard of them Fugazi
I've heard of them the ex never heard of
them Bad Brains of course I've heard of
them he wrote of course negative
approach parentheses pretty aggressive
death from Detroit these are a few good
starters I hope this message reaches you
and you enjoy all right I'll check those
up I'm still trying to get into fish
everybody they haven't quite Graeme all
right
[ __ ] guy needing ar-15 to defend
against coyotes oh my god he's in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere he's making
you cheese
hey sir Billiam [ __ ] I'm calling
[ __ ] on the guy who wrote in
claiming he needs an ar-15 to protect
his goats from coyotes all right all
right
okay well I hope you're a gun owner and
a [ __ ] rancher I grew up in a rural
town in New Mexico all right I wasn't a
Parmesan cheese rancher but we had two
sheepdogs and identify ot's living
directly behind our house to this day
every night you could hear the coyotes
howling the guy doesn't need a machine
gun he needs more than one dog oh [ __ ]
shots fired
seems like common sense honestly there
are breeds of dogs that have been bred
for centuries to protect sheep from
wolves well that is true and they didn't
have machine guns back then well I was
like one sheep Tarr two sheepdogs
and off our heard at coyotes you know
what that sounds like that sounds like
the sheepdogs are playing basketball and
the Coyotes are doing some an1 [ __ ] they
need to have a [ __ ] team game and
they got to feed that big man under the
[ __ ] rack and quit putting up threes
with no one up nobody underneath all
right wait a second
there are breeds of dogs that have been
bred for centuries to protect sheep from
wolves coyotes are [ __ ] compared to
wolves a few times when I was a kid I
was less than 15 feet from an adult
coyote and it just ran away
coyotes are also a lot smaller than
wolves claiming coyotes hunt in packs of
seven to twelve seems like an
exaggeration I don't like that word
seems that seems to me like you don't
know but it just sounds like [ __ ]
anyways the most baddest thing I've ever
seen a dog do was when my neighbor's
psycho dog chased away a coyote that
came near his turf my neighbor had this
crazy ugly mutt named butch butch was
the kind of dog where if the football or
baseball went over the fence into
Butch's yard the ball was gone one day
when I was a teenager and I was walking
up the road and there was a coyote
walking near me I wasn't scared because
the coyote was just minding his own
business
any [ __ ] wild and wild animals have a
different look on their face okay though
they're killers you know it's like
hookers you know there's a different
look it don't know hooker looks at you
it's real alright they're not [ __ ]
just trying to get a drink out of you
then I see butch jump over this
five-foot wall and land in a dead sprint
quote oh Jesus this is going to be good
I thought he beeline straight for the
coyote and without any hesitation or
fear hit the coyote like Walter Payton
on cocaine it definitely would have been
on sports centers top ten or some
YouTube video hardest hits in the NFL I
love that you went with Walter Payton he
was one of the most aggressive offensive
players Larry Csonka was the first
offensive player to get an unnecessary
roughness call he was on his way out of
bounds and someone went to hit him and
he just gave the guy of four
chef's to the face then butchering the
coyote got into a scrappy ghetto street
fight and eventually the coyote ran away
this all happened within ten yards of
where I was standing
well that was just one and it sounds
like the coyote [ __ ] threw some hands
too though dogs are badass they can
recognize threats to step up with no
fear they also used to be wolves still
like will wolf light right I'm not
saying it's a good light beer it's more
like bush light surely this guy can find
some large dogs who have instincts to
protect some goats rather than resort to
a military machine gun shooting coyotes
for sport is douchey my uncle has an
Anatolian Shepherd okay and it was
apparently bred for guarding lice
livestock massive dog I have a good
summer and go [ __ ] yourself well what's
the overhead what's the overhead on the
dog jesus [ __ ] christ look at that
goddamn thing the males way from fifty
to sixty five kilograms which is 110 to
143 pounds
females are forty to fifty five
kilograms that's 88 to 121 pounds
they're like 32 inches 29 to 32 inches
high 28 to 31 inches high Jesus Christ
that's a big-ass goddamn dog well let's
look at the kite at coyotes the tale of
the tape here coyote stats this is gonna
take me to Phoenix Coyotes coyote animal
Wikipedia let's see what you got here
actual coyote or a man no coyote attacks
on humans tax generally identify the
animal in question as simply coyote what
Eastern coyote Eastern KY oh here we go
see what they don't even have their
stats I don't like that that's like when
a movie goes to the theaters without
being reviewed the eastern coyotes is a
wild North American canine of mixed
coyote wolf and dog parentage parentage
that is present in New England New York
New Jersey Pennsylvania hi Alice [ __ ]
places so they're basically like stray
dogs that then got [ __ ] by wolves is
that what happened that didn't get
killed all right okay I don't care
anymore all right well you know some
people you got a hundred fifty pound
[ __ ] dog I mean what you got to feed
that thing every day how much of bullets
I mean I don't know if it's like a no no
hey the guy who wrote in with the
Parmesan cheese farm in feta cheese let
me know what do you think about what
this guy's saying I mean as far as I'm
concerned what the [ __ ] he just says you
got Swiss cheese on your farm now buddy
got a bunch of holes in your argument
please write back
all right cops use DNA to I can't say
this word genie Allah Allah ji website
geneology geneology all right let's look
this up GE any al ogy pro none
Annunciation I love this this is just
for dumb [ __ ] people how to pronounce
genealogy that is it here we go
geneology geneology allah why say
genealogy one more time hey I love her
they say like five times geneology
geneology geneology I think like why
didn't you just pick a man or a woman
you know I can't hear it oh now that
that lady said it now I know how to say
it
Oh what if a woman's listening well I
can't understand it unless a woman says
it
geneology cops used DNA to genealogy
website to website what that does okay
hey old Billy bald [ __ ] I just read the
police caught the Golden State Killer
using DNA obtained from geneology
geneology geneology website one of those
DNA / geneology geneology
geology websites that's going to make a
robot replacements the DNA website
responded by saying while in the did
well in while the database was created
for genealogy golf research it is
important that GED match know people who
didn't [ __ ] graduate high school
participants understand the possible use
of their DNA including identification of
relatives that may have committed crimes
or were victims of crimes I know you're
no legal analyst but I wanted to get
your thoughts on this by the way loved
you aren't crashing also come to a show
in Maine for Fox sex yeah I'm due to go
up there have a nice day and go [ __ ]
yourself I don't think you can get mad
at the fact that they caught a serial
killer if that's if they got the right
guy and you know what it was was it
actually wasn't that guy from what I
heard was it was a relative then it was
close enough and then they just narrowed
it down into that gene pool and they
judged that guy by his age they staked
out his [ __ ] house and then they got
like a soda can out of his garbage and
got his [ __ ] DNA and they nailed them
yeah it's one of those things where this
could be a great thing and you could get
a rid of it's it's all how its applied
and human beings do not have a great
track record of doing the right thing we
were all susceptible to the seven deadly
sins we are horribly flawed organisms
and then when you combine racism sexism
homophobia
greed ego and all of that [ __ ] yeah like
I don't know what could happen but I
mean I mean I'm all for this this
[ __ ] guy and he's like 71 I still
feel like he kind of got away with it
but you know just for the victims that
are still alive are family members
knowing that they got this guy and he's
gonna [ __ ] rot in jail for the rest of
his [ __ ] piece-of-shit life I think
it's a good thing oh my god it just came
up with an idea for a movie a serial
killer kills all his relatives before
they go on to [ __ ] a genealogy
website genealogy website genealogy
website it's a comedy you know they're
gonna find out that he's the [ __ ] jet
ski killer or some [ __ ] I don't know and
then he's got to be like you know and he
never goes to social events within the
family he's always been a loner all of a
sudden he starts showing up it's all the
Christmas parties and he's asking
questions and every party somebody dies
so he's got like 10 family members and
you know the first one he kills at
Thanksgiving maybe Halloween then
Thanksgiving and Christmas then there's
like a [ __ ] graduation I don't know
he just Flag Day he takes out his
[ __ ] uncle and then the local cops
you know they've never seen anything
like that they're in a quiet town to use
that trope and all of a sudden there's
his family members they're all dying you
know and then everybody feels bad for
the [ __ ] loner because he's losing
all his family members and then finally
one day the [ __ ] you know upstart you
know you got the [ __ ] old sheriff you
know he's he and everything god I'm too
old for this [ __ ] and then you got the
up stuck him you finished the [ __ ]
movie
he finished the [ __ ] movie I don't
have time for that [ __ ] all right black
Republicans everybody
dear mr. burr I've very much enjoyed
your show at the Fox in Atlanta I went
with my wife parents and in-laws thank
you for your laugh
and perspectives well thank you would
you mind sharing your thoughts on
Kanye's recent comments in the backlash
from Hollywood and Democratic elites why
do I always say elites there's
Republican elites too I myself am a
black Republican who changed parties
after the first Clinton administration
for great many reasons it's a bit
unnerving hearing people cringe over the
idea of a black Republican and it is
disrespectful to marginalize my opinions
in articulations because of my
affiliations it's very telling that
people defend who defended Kanye and
championed him when he attacked George
Bush are now casting him aside because
he does not agree with their groupthink
thank you for your service
and go [ __ ] yourself um yeah I mean I
there's this whole thing with liberals
that they feel like all racists are
Republicans and then they also aren't
aware of their own [ __ ] racist
thoughts prejudice thoughts and [ __ ]
up if you really pay attention to your
thoughts the information your brain is
gonna give you during the course of a
[ __ ] day you're gonna think sexist
[ __ ] homophobic [ __ ] racist you're just
gonna think [ __ ] that if you set it out
loud I've always said that if
everybody's thoughts were made public
could anybody go to work on Monday would
you have a [ __ ] job and you wouldn't
so on the other side the fact that Trump
didn't tweet once during Black History
Month said nothing as far as I'm aware
of on the 50th anniversary of Martin
Luther King the fact that he [ __ ]
could kind of see both sides with
neo-nazis and people who didn't like me
and Nazis said you know what both sides
are violent I I can't I understand that
level of backlash I don't understand
people that just feel that their Party
is just completely unplugged I don't
understand that having said that I think
Kanye
has an album coming out and MTV doesn't
exist anymore
and that people at his level they create
controversies as a way to get free
promotion that's what I think I don't I
don't take it seriously and nor do I
give a [ __ ] what his political
affiliation is I don't I don't care and
I don't care that you're a good for
Europe I get it you know a lot of people
become Republican when they make money
and then they realize how much money you
have to [ __ ] give away and [ __ ]
taxes if you actually have the audacity
to become successful and then all of a
sudden you have to [ __ ] you know you
have to pay for everybody else which I'm
all for helping people out but my thing
is if you're sitting around not doing
[ __ ] you know I told you that a long
time ago I you know this person in my
life was kept hitting me up for money
and I finally had to say the guy just
can't listen to if you're in a hole and
you're reaching up I will pull you out
of it but if you're faced out in it
digging it deeper every [ __ ] day I
mean what am I supposed to do I'm
throwing money into that you know you
want to keep doing [ __ ] drugs and I'm
also supposed to give you money go get
you [ __ ] life together and help
yourself out and I'll help you out you
know so I I see you know I see all sides
of this [ __ ] you know and sometimes I'll
and you know it's funny out here in
Hollywood people think you know someone
was telling me some people think you
voted for Trump which I didn't I kind of
see like I don't know it's it's really a
situation to situation decision you know
I mean sometimes you punch sometimes you
go for it on fourth down you know that
which depends on where you are in the
field that you got you have to look at
it that we can't just 100% we're going
for it every [ __ ] time or what but
kicking it away every [ __ ] time so I
I you know I'm old school where I
respect the just happy sir
that's your voting that you're
politically active in you're [ __ ]
paying
that's a lot more than I can say for
myself so god bless you but as far as
Kanye all of a sudden becoming
Republican I don't buy it
because I'm in show business and that
looks like a big [ __ ] that looks like
wrestling when all of a sudden the Hulk
became the bad guy and then eventually
he's gonna be shaking the blonde hair
we're in the [ __ ] orange and yellow
panties again you know all right
girlfriend wants to have sex before
marriage trunks I should say dear mr.
burr I'm sixteen years old still going
through high school I have a little
problem with my relationship I'm having
with this girl I met but here's a little
backstory about it okay okay about a
year ago one of my friends got a girl
pregnant
and let's just say during that time my
friend went through some hard time
knowing he was going to be a father to
the point he tried to kill himself but
failed you know Jesus Christ this guy
can't get anything right he can't put a
condom on right he can't [ __ ] off
himself
two days after his attempt he found out
that the baby didn't make it ending up
in a miscarriage Wow after seeing what
my went friend went through I decided I
was gonna wait till at least 18 to have
sex because I don't want to be like my
idiot friend well dude you don't want to
become a dad at 18 either wear a [ __ ]
condom all right but here's the story
about his story about me and the girl I
met her at work and we've been dating
for about six months now and I know what
you're going to hear me say next like I
really like her and all that [ __ ]
but get to the point alright anyways
screen goes black anyway she wants to
have sex even though I told her I'm
planning to wait after I told her that
she gave me that look three days later
she tried to pressure me into it I kept
saying no well you're learning one of
the great [ __ ] secrets about women is
you whatever the [ __ ] you want them to
do say you want to do the exact top
you know what I mean and then they will
[ __ ] it's it's unbelievable it's like
a [ __ ] cat let me see the Gallagher
you just do that [ __ ] pin you know
you call it cat it just [ __ ] doesn't
come at you you blow it off and it's
[ __ ] walking towards you anyways then
she went so far as to cry and sob about
me not wanting to have sex with her also
I like the idea of casual sex but I will
I want to experience love sex also I
think this girl lied to me to try to get
down my pants
what do you think I lie to you about
what birbal's
and stick your dick up your [ __ ]
aka go [ __ ] yourself you kind of all
over him the map here and you also left
out a lot of sentences she lied to you
like I don't know I just do what the
[ __ ] you want to do if what happened to
your friend had such a psychological
effect on you that you don't want to
have sex don't have sex with this person
that's it
and women cry and sob all the [ __ ]
time to try to get their [ __ ] way
it's [ __ ] okay unless she has
slugged him in the arm I don't know what
the [ __ ] they're crying about you know I
mean you're crying crying I could see if
you're upset if you're depressed but
you're crying here's the thing don't do
this but this is what I do because I've
said that to women like you're crying
over this how old do you watch how
quickly the tears stop and they
immediately switch to [ __ ] anger you
know I mean the their ability how fast
they can stop crying and then [ __ ]
start yelling at you like I going back
to whenever I cried when I was a kid I
mean I couldn't just stop that you know
I've you know and I would still be
crying they immediately just stop
[ __ ] crying BAM
so here's the deal to you're actually
what you're doing to this woman is you
you're actually you know like when you
play a video game one of those fighting
video games you don't know what you're
doing you just push a button bunch of
buttons and all of a sudden you've your
guide
some specials and you but you don't know
how to [ __ ] you did it that's what
you're doing with this you know this is
a completely roll reversed she's crying
like because you're not gonna [ __ ] her
like you sound like you're in a boyband
like you through acting the complete
opposite way as of every other guy has
so mind [ __ ] her that she's acting
you're getting treated like you [ __ ]
Justin Bieber or some [ __ ]
yeah she's making this all about herself
she feels [ __ ] rejected because this
is the thing women know the power that
they have over us and the fact that you
at the height of how you're at the
height of where you should not be able
to walk away from it or walking away
from it is [ __ ] with her in her level
of I don't know power you know I would
think this is also I'm really [ __ ]
stupid and don't know [ __ ] about women
but sometimes I do you know remember
that Mel Gibson movie where he was a
conspiracy theorist he threw out all
these crazy ones but every once in a
while he was right that's how I am with
women every once in a while I'm [ __ ]
right so what I will tell you this so
what I do know is you should do what the
[ __ ] you want to do all right
and yeah I believe Hootie and the
Blowfish said it best when they said let
her cry a song later crap whatever the
[ __ ] you said how smart was Darius
Rucker when he got out of that [ __ ]
band that was like when the [ __ ]
roadrunner just steps off the rock
before it [ __ ] crashes to the ground
and somehow he doesn't take the impact
you know now he does the country thing
right anyways that's the podcast
everybody I have some work to do today
and then I am just shutting this [ __ ]
down I'm not gonna [ __ ] do anything
for like three four days I have to get
past this goddamn cough I'm coming up on
two weeks with this and I don't want to
I don't want to you know I've never had
pneumonia and I don't
I [ __ ] get it you know cuz then every
time you get it's like if you tell once
you get frostbite you know every time
you open the refrigerator your [ __ ]
toes start tingling I don't want to deal
with that for the rest of my life all
right that's the podcast I'll check in
on you on Thursday I apologize that it
was late but uh you know I was you know
I'm fighting this [ __ ] thing off I'm
fighting the good fight here everybody
all right I'll check in on your Thursday
go [ __ ] yourself